the warning issued by the UN is blunt if
the world is to stop global temperatures
rising by dangerous amounts then it must
act quickly the report found that the
world is largely a very ill-prepared for
the risks of changing climate especially
the poor and most vulnerable who have
contributed least to this problem
climate change is already affecting
places such as Bangladesh the country is
regularly hit by floods and these could
become worse if temperatures rose still
further more global warming could also
cause the ice caps to melt and sea
levels to rise but catastrophe can still
be prevented if we act now immediately
and decisively we have the means to
build a better and more sustainable
world
the report says carbon emissions need to
be cut by up to 70% by 2050 and to zero
by 2100 fossil fuels must be replaced by
renewable energy sources the scientific
community has now spoken but we are
passing on the baton to politicians to
the decision making community the
panelists provided the information and
says the ball is now in the court of the
governments around the world it's up to
them to change their policies